rachel levine is a biological man until
just really a few years ago had a wife
and two kids now identifies as a woman
and in the biden administration that is
grounds for a promotion so the bite
administration now calls rachel levine
a female four-star admiral watch
i am honored to serve as the first
female four-star officer
of the u.s public health service
commissioned corps
all right whatever
call yourself whatever you want it's
when you force the rest of us to go
along
with what you call yourself when it's
not true that we have a problem and
that's what's happening now even if
you're a member of congress indiana
congressman jim banks for example is
just suspended from twitter for pointing
out that rachel levine is a biological
man
how long can this continue well it may
be ending the video platform rumble has
just joined forces with the crowdfunding
site locals and that platform promises
to permit free speech even if joe biden
doesn't like it dave rubin is one of the
founders of locals and joins us tonight
to explain what this will mean for
people who use social media to
communicate dave rubin first
congratulations on this second tell us
what this will mean for people who use
the internet
well look tucker we are going to create
a parallel ecosystem an ecosystem online
where people can tell you the truth
because the simple truth is that rachel
levine obviously is a biological male
and you know it's funny i've got the new
york times tweet right here they call
her a female in the tweet so who is
sharing misinformation we're taking out
congress people on twitter for
misinformation which is actually truth
and meanwhile the new york times is
spreading uh their alternate facts what
we are doing with this uh alliance of
rumble and locals is creating a
situation where people will be able to
say what they want to say we are not in
the business of policing people you want
to say bad things about me you want to
say mean things about tucker carlson you
are welcome to do it if you break the
laws of the united states guess what you
got a bigger problem than us but you
know there was a promise of a free and
open internet 20 years ago yes and
unfortunately over these last 20 years
we've learned that we were the products
our data our user habits we are being
manipulated in ways that we cannot
imagine and that is not our intention we
are going to build new servers we are
going to make sure that people can't
just have their websites blown up like
they did to parlor we're going to make
sure you don't get taken out for saying
basic truths like there are differences
between men and women or we're going to
let people debate political topics such
as whether vaccine mandates are
legitimate or not that's what we're
going to do that's actually what
everybody wants everyone just seems to
be afraid to say it
it's really quick you partially answered
my question but parlor just got pulled
right off the internet by amazon web
services
you believe this new venture will be
invulnerable to that
yes 100 tucker that is not an
exaggeration rumble has built an
incredible
infrastructure which locals will be
using and it'll be a b2b service and you
will be able to have your website you
can do what you want on there and we
provide you with the service and then
what you do on there is up to you and if
you do something illegal again that's a
problem now you have a legal problem
with the united states government or
whatever country you're in we're not in
the business of policing we're in the
business
of making business and actually doing
what everyone was promised which was had
a little something to do with free
speech a long time ago exactly it's not
so easy to do this which is why no one's
done it so i'm grateful you all are
spending the time and the money to pull
it to pull it off thanks for announcing
that here great to see you
thanks tucker if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell